there's no question about it I think
that the environmental movement in
general has suffered from from seeming
to represent a pretty narrow segment of
society and that's not the case
obviously you know we're out there
fighting for clean water or clean air
and saw we're doing for everybody of all
economic or income levels of all races
of all religions and all political
parties and so on you know there's no
discrimination in terms of the work that
we're doing but largely speaking the
environmental movement over the last 34
years has been dominated by by middle to
upper-class you know white folks who
have been leading the charge on this
stuff and I think that's unfortunate i
mean i think there's some kind of
reasonable explanations for that but
it's it's unsustainable because it had a
couple of x first of all we're failing
to reach a large segments of the
population that are actually being even
more hammered by environmental pollution
than a lot of the kind of you know upper
middle-class folks who are who are part
of these organizations so they have even
more at stake if you live in a turban
area or a low income area whether it's a
you know or a rural area and so on a lot
of times you're more subjected to air
and water pollution than other
communities I also think that we have
not done a good job of appealing to
folks as well and I think that that's
why we've tended to be vulnerable to the
tree hugger or the kind of elitist type
of tag and I think that we fail to do
that you know luckily I think that
that's really changing first of all a
lot of environmental justice oriented
kamiya organizations are starting and
are actually you know are thriving
around the country and you've got people
like majare who are doing terrific work
and who are really becoming serious
voices and influential players in this
movement but not just in this movement
but in political circles as well and
that's vitally important and it's long
overdue but I
I can't say how thrilled I am that it's
happening now because we're not Amy the
bottom line is this if it's just the
environmentalists trying to do this work
on our own we're not going to do it
we've got to enlarge the tent to have it
represent all sectors of society and
we've got to include everybody everybody
has to see themselves in
environmentalist we have to get away
from the idea that's a dirty word which
is you know what unfortunately longer
our opponents have successfully achieved
is this making environmentalism somehow
you know a fringe activity I think it's
becoming pretty apparent with climate
change especially but all the different
environmental problems we have this is
no longer a fringe issue this is front
and central to how we're going to do
going forward and not just in terms of
our health but also economically and
otherwise so luckily I think the war is
trying to catch on and and whether we
wanted to it or not this is becoming a
world movement and it needs to